jacques chirac s'envole cet après-midi
pour l'asie il participera à partir de
vendredi à hanoi un sommet de la
francophonie qui réunira 30 chefs d'état
et de gouvernement l'occasion de faire
le point sur la pratique du français
aujourd'hui au vietnam
reportage marie-hélène bono jean louis
moulin aujourd'hui le vietnam compte 350
milles francophobe la plupart vivent à
hanoi à peine soixante dix mille
personnes parlent encore couramment le
français
comme cet homme auteur d'un livre
entièrement écrits dans la langue de
molière ou avez vous appris le français
à l'école et y narre combats qui sont
les vietnamiens qui parlent français
aujourd'hui la plupart les vieux les
jeunes les jeunes tpo pourquoi parce que
au cours ap l'intérêt économique pour
les jeunes du bas canton par l'armée il
est plus facile de trouver un nouveau
pourtant dans le primaire seul le
français est enseignée comme langue
étrangère dans cette école bilingue à hô
chi minh-ville 400 enfants de 6 à 11 ans
après notre langue est un bon pari
il ya combien
d'abord paysage tu apprends depuis
combien de temps très difficiles
quand je serai
je la plupart du temps leurs parents
sont francophones il reste attaché aux
faux fait c'est une affaire de coeur
bonjour l'anglais est servi à utiliser
ce moment dans le commerce se tandis que
les français vont faire utiliser
élan dans la culture pour nous dans la
culture en général
et puis dans la lecture de livres
français le gouvernement vietnamien est
favorable à la reconquête du français
dans le pays
soucieux surtout d'attirer les
investisseurs merci beaucoup